estamos en un área comercial de uno de
los barrios importantes del occidente de
kiev son las seis de la tarde y este es
el panorama que nos encontramos está
totalmente oscura la electricidad no
está funcionando desde las 12 del día
pero ayer fue peor se fue desde las 10
de la mañana y a las 7 de la tarde
cuando cerraron los comercios no había
regresado Y esto es una situación
realmente mejor que la semana anterior
cuando kiev se quedó sin electricidad
después de esos ataques contra la
infraestructura energética que no
solamente dejó a la capital sino al
resto del país a oscuras aquí nos
cuentan que bueno que han tomado
alternativas muchos de los pequeños
comercios que vemos en la calle han
comprado plantas eléctricas Pero hay
otros comercios que están totalmente
cerrados porque no tienen como
abastecerla en la electricidad para sus
clientes y nos cuentan estas personas
muchas de ellas que trabajan en la calle
que bueno Están acostumbradas en
invierno pero que si esto sucede después
de menos 10 grados de temperatura no
podrán trabajar en las calles y algunos
tienen fortuna la fortuna de que en sus
casas Tienen calefacción de gas pero si
vemos muchos de los edificios que están
a nuestro alrededor están oscuras Eso
quiere decir que estas personas tienen
también estas calefacciones con plantas
con energía eléctrica lo que hace pensar
que dentro de estas casas posiblemente
está haciendo mucho más frío que la
misma calle donde estamos en este
momento a menos 3 grados centígrados lo
que indica que va a ser un invierno muy
duro porque como hemos venido repitiendo
a lo largo de nuestros informes desde
que estamos en Ucrania están esperando
mayores ataques contra la
infraestructura eléctrica y piensan que
este va a ser tal vez el invierno más
duro de sus vidas